thierry mariani des députés européens du
rassemblement national séries bonjour
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors bloqué les migrants les
réfugiés d'ailleurs c'est un débat
sémantique qui a toute son importance on
y reviendra plus tard si on a le temps
donc bloquer les migrants s'est
manifestement votre solution c'est ce
que vous avez twitté alors première
question on les bloque ou sur leurs
bateaux de fortune en méditerranée en
les empêchant d'accoster on attend
qu'ils arrivent à la frontière on les
renvoie dans leur pays d'origine en
admettant qu'il nous dise d'où lui
viennent et s'ils viennent d'un pays en
guerre ou d'un pays où il ya la famille
est ce qu'on prend la responsabilité de
les renvoyer n'y fait un tri entre les
immigrés économiques et les autres biens
connaît la réalité c'est une chose très
difficile à faire
je veux une politique ou en réalité
l'europe se protège tout en restant
humaine que nous propose l'union
européenne aujourd'hui elle nous propose
en réalité de quasiment rien changé
c'est à dire tous ceux qui veulent
rentrer en europe et puis après on
essaye de répartir à la charge
vous avez vu cette intervention où le
maître mot c'est désormais solidarité
mais ça veut rien dire puisque chacun
sait très bien que un immigrant
clandestin qui met le pied en italie ou
en grèce avec schengen c'est désormais
le moyen d'aller partout dans l'europe
et donc en réalité ce que nous demandons
c'est réellement un changement de
politique à savoir faire en sorte que
ces immigrés n'arrive plus sur le sol
européen
or excusez moi mais j'ai une musique
j'entends le générique en permanence
j'ai pas ce qu'il est en train de se
passer c'est très difficile de parler
dessus alors attendez il ya peut-être un
problème technique
peut-être que ça va être réglé à ce que
vous avez entendu monsieur mariani est
ce que c'est bon oui j'entends la même
temps la musique est en train de baisser
mais j'ai toujours une musique je fais
si y'a quand même de parler
voilà un pays qui font tout leur
possible
merci beaucoup je disais en réalité la
solution c'est pas d'accueillir tout le
monde et après de voir comment se
débrouille parce qu'en réalité c'est ce
que nous propose sa l'union européenne
le nouveau plan des migrations qu'à
présenter madame von der leyen
je veux pas rentrer dans les détails
techniques on met à part d'ubs là où en
réalité c'était le premier pays
ou le leu sans poser le pied qui de
prêter le problème
désormais il ya cette notion de
solidarité ou en clair on nous annonce
ce qui est d'ailleurs encore plus
inquiétant pour la france que en
fonction des solidarités des familles
des clans etc
ils pourront aller dans d'autres pays
nous ce qu'on demande c'est quoi c'est
qu'en réalité les frontières soient
vraiment protéger je vais répondre
précisément à vos questions est-ce que
les bateaux doivent être accueillis à
marseille comme j'ai entendu
précédemment avant ou ailleurs bien sûr
que non est-ce qu'il faut sauver les
migrants qui sera en mer bien sûr que
oui
mais le vrai travail ça devrait être de
les renvoyer à leur point de départ et
pas de les accompagner à leur point de
départ en sécurité mais pas de les
amener en grèce ensuite je voudrais
qu'on arrête de répéter toute une série
de choses qui en réalité sont fausses
j'ai devant moi et j'invite tous vos
auditeurs à aller sur le site de lieux
hanna schaer c'est-à-dire l'office des
nations unies consacré aux réfugiés et
c'est un site très intéressant parce que
chaque jour il fait le compte des
immigrants qui ont traversé la
méditerranée avec les nationalités
quel est aujourd'hui le premier pays
pour depuis le 1er janvier
quel est le même pour cent des personnes
qui ont traversé la méditerranée
viennent de tunisie la tunisie comme
vous le savez comme pays où il ya aucune
guerre ensuite deuxième pays
c'est l'algérie avec 12,4 pour cent il
n'y a aucune guerre et ensuite pareil
dans les premiers on trouve le maroc
avec 5,6 pour cent ce qui veut dire quoi
ce qui veut dire que 40 % des immigrants
qui traversent la méditerranée sont
aujourd'hui d'algérie du maroc ou de la
tunisie
donc on arrête de nous dire que que
c'est des pays avec lesquels on est il
ya des guerres et en plus de sueur
procédé pays que l'union européenne aide
donc on doit avoir les moyens de dire
très clairement à ces pays on vous aide
l'union européenne vous aident ou la
france vous aide écoutez il faut que
vous récupériez vaut sans papiers
autrement pardonnez-moi des couillons
qui passent leur temps à payer monsieur
mariani moi je vais utiliser d'autres
chiffres si vous me permettez d'ailleurs
utilisez des chiffres dont la
crédibilité ne devrait pas être remise
en cause puisqu'il vient du parlement
européen d'où vous êtes vous même issue
monsieur mariani c'est des chiffres qui
datent de l'année 2019
les pays européens ont offert une
protection à près de 300000 personnes et
près d'une de ces personnes sur trois
venaient des séries de syrie donc ni
l'algérie ni du maroc ni de tunisie on
parle bien deux scieries en pays en
guerre et sachez d'ailleurs que sûr ccja
lien l'allemagne en a accueilli 71 %
la france est donc bien bien loin oui
mais ça c'est les chiffres excusez moi
comment la vie qui date de 2018 ou 2019
si c'est pas tacher 2009 c'est des
chiffres d'accord voile et ami d'alors
on est dans les parties en 2020 n'est
pas encore fini mais je vous invite
saleilles aliaga nos fils qui s'appelle
l'office national office des nations
unies pour les réfugiés politiques
c'est ce qu'on appelle du unhcr si vous
ne croyez pas je vous invite à aller sur
votre tablette en ce moment envoyé c'est
la faute au président a exactement un
quart d'heure il ya tous les chiffres
depuis le 1er janvier
puisque chaque année les actualiser
leurs statistiques donc depuis le 1er
janvier
la situation est totalement différente
je persiste je signe
40% des personnes qui franchissent la
méditerranée depuis le 1er janvier sont
d'algérie du maroc ou de tunisie vit ces
machines un rendement sans essai et les
60% restants viennent d'où monsieur
mariani cent restants il vient que
l'exemple le pays suivant ses 8 % alors
ensuite si on additionne les pays en
guerre dans ce premier tableau des 15
pays les plus importants vous avez
l'afghanistan à cette vie à 7,9 et la
syrie à 7,5
c'est à dire en gros moins de 20 %
c'est-à-dire moins d'or réfugiés sur
cinq
donc on arrête de nous dire que les
réfugiés politiques qui débarque en
méditerranée viennent de pays en guerre
selon les nations unies c'est moins d'un
sur cinq
voilà c'est les chiffres aujourd'hui
réfugié politique un monsieur marini en
tout cas 15% des réfugiés au monde
je parle du monde sont accueillis par
des pays dits développés en seulement 15
% des réfugiés au monde des déplacés
passe par l'europe en tout cas où par
l'amérique le canada où ce qu'on veut et
d'ailleurs l'afrique accueille la grande
majorité des africains on parle de 70 %
de déplacés africains qui se déplace au
sein même de l'afrique ce n'est pas
l'europe qui est le premier continent à
subir cette vague migratoire
ce n'est pas vrai comment on explique
alors qu'on a l'impression inverse en
tout cas que certains en font un peu le
se valent leur cheval de bataille
écoutez c'est certainement l'europe qui
ces dernières années a accueilli quand
je vois le changement qu'on a dans
certaines villes ou villages de france
laurent a accueilli assez à la limite
excusez moi je me vais peut-être choquer
je me moque de savoir si d'autres
payants dont avec lui plus que nous je
constate qu'on doit accueillir ce qu'on
peut assimiler ce qu'on peut j'allais
dire est d'intégrer ce qu'on peut
accueillir en toute dignité
vous êtes salué la tête et alors vous
savez l'humanité pardonnez moi si c'est
pour accueillir des gens aient laissé je
pèse mes mots pourrir dans un camp au
bord d'une autoroute fm ou le 20e
arrondissement
je vois pas où est l'humanité je vois
qu'aujourd'hui il sincèrement l'europe
n'est plus en état de continuer à
accueillir autant de personnes si des
pays comme l'allemagne veulent continuer
à la limite qui le font qu'ils le
fassent pardon mais on n'est pas obligé
tous de suivre l'allemagne parce que
merkel veut avoir du personnel bien payé
pour le pacs ou payer plutôt pour le
patronat allemand voilà aujourd'hui
qu'on arrête de culpabiliser les
européens les européens ont fait
beaucoup d'efforts et je le répète et je
signe et je vous mets au défi madame de
me prouver le contraire
depuis le 1er janvier 80 % des immigrés
dans les dix premiers pays ayant franchi
la méditerranée ne venait pas de pays en
guerre
d'accord alors j'ai du mal tout à
l'heure vous parlez de 40% maintenant 80
% en tout cas également je tiens à
rappeler les chiffres que j'ai utilisés
viennent du parlement européen vont vous
même vous êtes issu donc des chiffres
officiels merci monsieur mariani d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur super nes
est malhonnête
si vous coupez là vous êtes mal on est à
ce sujet la malhonnête mais moi finir
peut-être vous avez cité les chiffres de
2010 9 g on allait voir de 2020 et je
vous rappelle donc en parlez pas du même
chiffre de la même année je parle des
derniers chiffres voilà
et deuxièmement je répète mais quatre
pays des trois pays du maghreb font bien
de 40% et simplement 20% des réfugiés
viennent de pays en guerre
s'il faut peut-être pour qu'on puisse
parler de la même chose quand on compare
les mêmes allez vous avez des chiffres
de l'année 2010 je parle vous le dit
avec le sourire des chiffres communiqués
par les nations unies on a désolé
monsieur mariani on a un petit problème
de connexion mais en tout cas j'ai bien
saisi ce que vous vouliez me dire vous
parliez de chiffres 2020 communiquées
par les nations unies je vous coupe et
je suis vraiment désolé on n'a plus
beaucoup de temps en tout cas merci
d'avoir été en direct avec nous sur rt
france je rappelle que vous êtes député
européen du rassemblement national merci